ceci est la nouvelle longue
tout le monde est heureux à présent
chacun est à sa place il n'y a ni fin ni
violence
soyez les bienvenus dans la réserve
il n'y a pas de souffrance la bâche
chacun est à sa place nul n'est jamais
seul c'est ce que j'ai toujours voulu
pour toi vous êtes ici chez vous à
présent a ajouté cet endroit il selon
vous transportez on n'est jamais seul
ici tout le monde est connecté c'est pas
sans la force et les faut quelqu'un
comme vous pour le guider pour
l'intégrer au corps social
vous pouvez échapper à votre
conditionnement comme nous tous rien de
ce que vous verrez ne sera plus jamais
comme avant
c'est vrai que tu connais le sauvage ici
personne seront de la chance que vous
avez la vie de tout le monde parfait
séparer de quoi parler on tue tout ça
ce qui se passe
si vous arrêtez d'en prendre vous
pourriez découvrir ce que vous ressentez
on doit arrêter le sauvage avant que
cela le débat ce qu'ils vous ont fait
est inconcevable
ce qu'il vaut francs inimaginable
mon parc rebelles si on reste ici
si tu n'es pas heureux tu n'es rien du
tout